welcome back everybody we are here with
Jennifer
gner our new Netflix movie is called
family switch it got us thinking about
how many iconic families we've loved in
movies and shows over the years so it is
time for a game celebrating those
fictional families this is one big
[Music]
happyy you can go so many different ways
with the ending of that um Heavenly
Father a little help with the game
please okay thank
you God comes here yeah well hey Kelly
and Jennifer Garner oh my me I am such a
big fan I am such a big
fan don't tell Kelly but I'm rooting for
you okay here's how the game works don't
sass back now don't sass back don't sass
back here's how the game works girl I'm
going to read a trivia question and the
answer to that question is the name of a
famous fictional f family or character
now steals are allowed and I'd advise
that you wait until the end of the
question to answer but like most things
in life that's up to you okay it's
Jennifer Garner versus Kelly Clarkson
benad drill chicken versus wet towel in
the dryer and a family siiz prize a
family siiz prize for their respective
side of the audience is on the line so
this is big this is
there okay okay focus focus all right
these two are very competitive sh that's
good I wish you Lu kind of okay here wow
that's just nasty you playing dirty
already Kelly here we go here's the
first question I love it this family
forgot their son Kevin not once Jennifer
mallister family home alone you got it
it is the mallister so so fast it's so
fast that was so fast there you go
that's oh look at that one point for
Jennifer how's that feel Kelly
oh my go it's really good you speed okay
okay the mcallisters mcallisters with
that big ass house they probably paid $2
200,000 for that back in
1990 of BU okay here's your next
question in this family when the father
met the mother she was bringing up three
very lovely girls the bunch it is the
Brady
Bunch
yes we got ourselves a tie here this is
a game now Mara Marsha Mara poor Jan
poor Jan okay okay here's your next
question the wissow family on family
matters Carl Winslow Family Matters car
Winslow uh he hasn't asked the question
yet
boo well I'm sorry Kelly it looks like
you jump the gun and that's the show and
you jumped the gun
Kelly oh do I get that point I'm going
to give you a point just because here
Jennifer
Garner what kind of show is
this God's in control now okay now let
me read the whole question the Winslow
Family on Family Matters was always
being interrupted by a lovable nerd
named it was
urel there you go there you go I wait
for the whole question okay here's your
next question Poppins went to take care
of Jane and Michael who Banks it is the
banks you got
[Applause]
it okay here's your next question now
what was the name of the family from
both TV and film who had some odd
members like an uncle who turned on
light bulbs The Adams Family it is The
Adams
Family
wow
wow uh-oh you that sound right there
means like we have time for one more
famous fictional family and this one is
worth 400
points very exciting God here it is this
is for all the chips here we go this
family went on a number of vacations
including a Vegas vacation and a
Christmas Vacation ch ch um Griswalds
but yeah you you
okay it is the g no
no I I will not take it I will not take
it I only remembered Chevy Chase in the
European Vacation I did not remember gzs
in the moment she gets it I didn't get
it I didn't get it I didn't get it
Jennifer Garner is the
winner I I could remember the entire the
rusty hat I could remember all of it but
not their name it's interesting um okay
we're all winners though we're all
family we're all winners here the
vitamic verion blender features a 625 W
Motor with four blades all five speeds
and comes with multiple accessories that
can blend tough ingredients in the palm
of your hands that's nice and you're all
getting a Vitamix immersion blender
bundle worth of
$ family switch is now streaming on
Netflix so be sure to check it
[Music]
out
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home